we're constantly being asked who does  Hollywood have today who can match the  brilliance of a Betty Davis the beauty  of a Greta Garbo or the magnificence of  a Katharine Hepburn well let me present  the class of 71 none of them has ever  been nominated before some of them are  making their first appearances on the  screen and all of them are superb  actresses the nominees for Best  Performance by an actress are carries  Snodgrass in Diary of a mad house wife  Glenda Jackson in women in love Sarah  miles and Ryan's daughter Ali MacGraw in  love story jane alexander in the great  white hope the envelope please  the winner is Glenda Jackson in women  life accepting the award for  you know  I know if Glenda Jackson were here  tonight  she'd be terribly terribly thrilled  she's 100% a professional and this is a  great night for professionals I know  she'd like to thank you most sincerely  for this great honor thank you  [Applause]  you